the published documents purport to show
the degree to which the Ukrainian
military is struggling in the conflict
but also supposedly show that the U.S
has extensively penetrated Russian
intelligence units and is also spying on
close allies including Ukraine's
military and political leaders the leak
that was first reported by the New York
Times includes details about Ukraine's
military strength and its casualty
counts along with those of Russian
forces
the Times report says one senior U.S
official called The League a massive
intelligence breach made worse because
it lays out to Russia just how deep
American intelligence operatives have
managed to get into the Russian military
apparatus
but some of the details in the documents
appear to have been altered to present a
Rosier picture of the Russian military
fueling speculation that they're being
used in a propaganda drive there are
some aspects of the document that have
some authenticity to them but there are
also indications that this may be a
Russian disinformation campaign which
they're very good at it's attempting to
Target strategic intelligence sharing
between the United States and Ukraine
and try to you know create a bad faith
relationship there the documents also
appear to reveal U.S national secrets
about the Middle East China and even
North Korea the White House is working
at damage control with its traditional
allies many of whom are believed to have
been angered at the reported extent of
U.S Espionage it's also working at
reassuring those allies that the U.S is
able to keep its secrets
and what the White House most needs is
concrete information about the leaks
from both the Pentagon and the
Department of Justice
Mike Hanna Al Jazeera Washington